said that sugar sugar was on roads
telling this jordan story where
he'll play uh like so the three of us
are playing
jordan will he he will only bet he won't
just play to play yeah
there's always money online yeah so
he'll know how much money you make
so he'll go whatever you're making a
million dollars a year he says i'll bet
you a hundred thousand
you're making five million a year i'll
bet you 200 000. so he based bet
of what your income is and then yeah
sugar was saying he beat this guy you
know it was like 70 g's
and it's not like yeah give it to him
when he can he was like dude where's my
money and he's like i'll get two he's
like no
i need it by tomorrow at 9 00 am dude
where the [ __ ] is my money the guy's
like jesus christ
yeah he wants that money he wants speech
they don't mention this in the dark
i don't think you become that insanely
good without being
a little bit off in that sense yeah his
work work ethic was insane like when he
was filming a space jam
he he uh he had other players in the
league come out
and so when he would be on a 12-hour day
of set
you know for space jam then they would
play like three hours of basketball
the who's who would be yeah yeah canelo
alvarez is that way he's obsessed like
they say he's just
always in the gym oh really yeah it's
like andy ruiz
was training with those guys and he goes
i mean he lost 50 pounds he's like
you know i'm i'm with these dudes it's a
whole different decision yeah
the only one close to jordan would like
mindset would have been uh
kobe yeah yeah but kobe also like
said he joined he said i learned from
yeah from him yeah
called jordan apparently oh yeah yeah he
said he would call him up yeah two in
the morning like hey man i'm thinking
about like
and then kobe would be mean to you like
if like dwight howard and kobe didn't
get along because dwight thought he was
lazy
sorry you're fired yeah
kobe like with dwight howard like he
wasn't playing well like he was in a rut
and then kobe would be at the gym at
like four in the morning and then dwight
would get that at the regular time like
seven he'd be like what are you doing
man
treat him like [ __ ] he'd bully him
basically he called up a complaint
jordan went hard on people too that's
what i'm in uh her in the face yeah he
said to his coach
i'm not playing with when jeremy lin was
playing with him and
lynn he just felt like wasn't showing up
he goes i'm not getting on the court
with him i don't want to play with him
and then he called like kobe kobe then
he called like one of his teammates
who i sat next on the plane and he was
like uh i don't want to play with him
man four in the morning he's like what
he was i don't i don't want him i don't
want him on the team he's here
just talking to him he would take
everything personally but i mean do you
guys do
you guys think that's like mean or is it
they just have a different competitive
edge
i mean that's just if you're that good
i'm going to listen yeah
that's what i'm saying like if you're
that but if you're just like if you're
just like
that's what i'm saying like i don't
think if bill paxton was like i don't i
don't want to play with dennis rodman i
don't like that but maybe
shut the [ __ ] up but if it's jordan or
kobe or
once in a generation town i'm to listen
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
because some people were like
winners made it seem like i mean he was
being mean or whatever but it's like
he could back it up they're extreme
winners they're like winning is
everything and losing is
the worst thing bill parcells was that
way apparently like his i think his
ex-wife is talking about it like
when he would lose it would be it would
like
he felt like there was bile in his in
his throat like he couldn't like
literally physically he would get sick
like you know it's like some people are
just i mean there's you know
so ultra competitive even it sounds like
exhausted me jordan's friend
like even if you've got a girl over him
he may not have friends like it depends
yeah yeah bro just kicks it with his
kids
i don't know i don't know that i don't
know if you know that's your dad
yeah be exhausting oh like that damn
damn i don't have money to bet you
right i've lost my life yeah man
you pay me all yeah they work for them
right kids work for the jordan break
they do oh yeah
wow he does not know what else are you
gonna do a guy like that though his
family is probably his
you know like that's yeah part of the
competition that's part of like
you know there's there's there's us and
then well but also you can't
if you marry michael jordan have kids
with them you know that's like being
upset you by a pit bull and it's
aggressive like you you signed up you
made [ __ ] michael michael jordan
jaguar yeah it's not going to be a pet
like a dog yeah
his kid played at i think florida
atlantic fiu i think
florida oh that was when he just did
yeah i wonder how he would be like did
he try to coach or anything like that
who jordan yeah he owned he owns uh the
bobcats i know that
he doesn't he doesn't all right he's no
it's too competitive yeah
like they're they're they they drafted
kwame brown and
you know and jordan vouch for him and
then saw he wasn't very good
i guess the guy said something to jordan
jordan was 50 at the time
and this was his first day and jordan
goes hey let's play one on one the kid's
like dude you don't want to do this and
jordan's like yeah i do
he beat him so bad they said he like his
his confidence was
he he was a bust because sometimes he
never came back because
he destroyed him one-on-one 50 50.
he was up in the office in his suit and
was like oh
this is the kid i vouched for dude let's
play one-on-one and
beat him so bad that the kid was a guy
get in your kitchen gets in your kitchen
because you always leave one one window
open in your house
everybody thinks they got all the
windows closed in their house you find
that one window is covered
like the night stalkers just a little
little illusion yeah just a little
compromise and he pop out and
and then now he's in your kitchen he's
moving [ __ ] around
and you hear clanging and now you can't
do it they're very that's what it does
you can't you your house ain't locked
up to that degree dude that's an exact
quote from the night stalker that's
right
is it really yes oh that's exactly what
he
no i'm telling
hey i thought his uh baseball career was
pretty interesting too jordan's
never did an interview with sports
illustrated again after they said it's
michael
oh yeah yeah baseball yep then the
baseball player said nobody worked like
him nobody worked that hard i mean
yeah there was sam not playing since
high school and going
like he wasn't awful that's what they
were saying and here's the other thing
neither was tim tebow dude also
never played that was pretty good yes
and now you know t was going to try out
with the
with the jacksonville jaguars that tied
in you signed up tight end
they signed up they signed them they
signed them really you know you know
urban myers is the coach and that him
and timmy are
super close and they're also next door
neighbors oh
and timmy wants to play still mm-hmm huh
how old is he
he's pretty younger yeah he's going to
be older for
he has to be i think i'm two years older
than that would they would they
use him as a is there is there are there
he's thirty-three so he plays where he's
always walks back
oh yeah same age pretty much no don't
ask that question okay
no but no a fleet up no no no
no no you could use like a wildcat
package or something
but he wouldn't play tight end you'd go
over to quarterback oh
you could do a shift where the start of
the quarterback
yeah or he does the jump pack he's a
giant man so i would imagine he catching
balls for him i don't know what his
hands are like
great hands [ __ ] athletes
oh you want to talk about a savage like
mentally tough as [ __ ]
mentally you can't phase him too and
everybody
how much scrutiny he gets and [ __ ] he
gets speed
how old is he now 30 33
not terrible not terrible dude
is that like your average age it's not
it's not like you know he's not like 36
yeah he and probably two years left two
years especially at tight end
how old is gronk he's still playing
right tight end yeah gronk is
he's a gold holder really i'd say like
probably
36. there's no reason why he can't
tim really well i mean i'm fascinated to
see that will he start
i doubt it because but there's a lot of
blocking too right
just depends what you are yeah there's
blocking tight ends there's receiving
tight ends there's time so he must he
must be working out a lot and stuff and
just staying he always works out too
right always
yeah he's a monster dude there's not
listen there's not a harder worker in
the room and you guys are friends with
him right yeah that's my boy yeah
he's a [ __ ] great great guy you did
his charity show yeah he's a great guy
he bombed and you killed it right very
good i had a really really
good yeah i didn't do well um but i had
an amazing talk with him
about religion and and sort of but he's
very very
articulate on that subject like he's
very grounded in his faith but he can
back it up well think about it everyone
questions listen
since you've been a kid it really
questions his faith so if you they
thought it was like false or something
no
it's just you know if you're that balls
deep in religion you know i do it to my
uh father-in-law all the time he grew up
super catholic on easter i mean him got
into it not in a bad way but
if you're going to have that discussion
yeah if you're going to question someone
on the on their face
you better have some legit points yeah
well yeah because if you go with the
basic [ __ ]
it's like making fun of david foster for
being fat he's been fat his entire life
he roasts people for a living so if you
if you're who
uh dave david lucas oh i was like who's
david david so if you're gonna roast
david lucas
you can you have something else you
gotta have something yeah so if you're
gonna question tim's face he's heard it
he's he's heard it all and he's ready to
go yeah it's like a heckler like like if
you heckle rogan or brian or [ __ ]
dane cook dude you you what you think
saying you're not funny it's gonna work
yeah you don't think they've heard that
from day one growing up in boston
yeah so you better come up with
something original otherwise you can get
annihilated
but it seems like i mean just from being
an outsider it seems like he just keeps
his
religion like pretty much like it's his
thing he holds
he probably just casually invited you
though and probably wasn't like
you need to do that i didn't want to
disappoint him so brandon probably can
just see him going
yeah i showed up every wednesday
i i stopped going because i talked to
the pastor and i said uh
i said yeah i'm listening to you guys
talking and it was basically networking
so all these famous people i was like
this doesn't feel right yeah
so and then and then i i said uh
so in the you were talking about today
because they always have like there's
always a theme every wednesday
and we do at the beverly hills hotel and
we got done i asked the pastor i said
so like my dad and brother don't believe
in god what happens to them because
hopefully they do man otherwise they're
going to hell i was like that can't be
right
they're great people they're nice people
so what happens to the people that don't
have the opportunity to learn about
catholic or christianity how about that
when i get off stage with the laugh
actually
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song